was würdest du machen wenn du an einem
einzigen Tag 2,5 Millionen ausgeben
dürftest vielleicht einen Heli Mieten im
teuersten Restaurant der Stadt Essen
oder einfach alles kaufen was du schon
immer haben wolltest ist in diesem Fall
leider nicht möglich denn ich spreche
nicht von Euros sondern vietnamesischen
Dong was die zweitschwächste Währung der
Welt ist und auch wenn wir nicht alles
kaufen können lässt sich damit schon
wirklich eine Menge anstellen in diesem
Format bereite ich die
unterschiedlichsten Städte der Welt um
herauszufinden wie weit man mit 100 € in
24 Stunden kommt und damit herzlich
Willkommen zu 100 € in Neu der
günstigsten Stadt Südostasiens
[Musik]
Sega we rich 2,5 Millionen
vietnamesische Dong ein Euro sind 25.000
Dong und wir haben 500.000 erscheine
geil geil geil geil finde ich Hammer ist
tatsächlich seit Jahrzehnten eine der
schwächsten Währung überhaupt 2006 und
2008 war der Dong tatsächlich weltweit
die am schwächsten bewertete Währung
heute ist der Dong immer noch die
zweitschwächste Währung und obwohl es
Münzen gibt sind sie ziemlich schwer zu
finden und praktisch alles wird mit
Schein bezahlt der kleinste Schein sind
5 was ungefähr 3,3 Cent sind ob und wie
gut wir aber mit diesen 2,5 Millionen
durch den Tag kommen wird sich zeigen
aber selbst Millionäre haben morgens ein
leeren Magen bedeutet gehen zurück ins
Hotel um dort zu frühstücken wir
schlafen im five stars Lake ein Hotel in
dem man voll eingerichtete Apartments
für eine oder mehrere Nächte mieten kann
komplett neu voller Service super schick
und mega modern und was man hier für den
unschlagbaren Preis von einer Millionen
also ca 30 Euro pro Nacht bekommt ist
einfach nur verrückt eine komplette
Küche mit riesenkühlschrank
Induktionsherd und eigener Waschmaschine
würden es uns möglich machen dort
unabhängig zu bohren dazu noch ein
abgetrennter Wohnbereich mit Couch und
Fernsehen ein richtig gutes Bad und ein
eigener Balkon und nur einige Stockwerke
drunter in genauso einem voll
eingerichteten apartment was auf den
ersten Blick auch etwas wird war findet
man das Frühstücksbuffet also wir sind
quasi in einer Wohnung das ist quasi im
Wohnhaus in dem aber auch von Stock 1
bis 4 ein paar Hotelzimmer sind also so
Service Apartments die sind ziemlich
groß und dieser Raum hier sieht schon
sehr quasi nach unserer Wohnung aus aber
hier werden wir jetzt sitzen und speisen
drüben gibt
es an die Auswahl macht zwar klein sein
aber das Buffet war richtig gut und vor
allem mega frisch und das Beste im Preis
von 38 € pro Nacht für das Hotelzimmer
in Begriffen wir haben Früchte wir haben
Apfelsaft wir haben Cappuccino wir haben
drei kleine Gerichte japanische Gerichte
wir haben hier ein bisschen Gemüse
Zwiebeln im heißt wir haben miesesuppe
wir haben alles wir hätten noch Essen
bestellen können wir hätten vorbestellen
können wir hätten andere Arten von Ei
bestellen können im Prinzip genau das
was ich mir vorstelle um direkt im Hotel
zu essen und gestärkt in den Tag in so
einer riesen Metropole rein zu starten
auf zu unserer ersten Attraktion und da
können wir zu Fuß hin aber
108.000 wird Dong für drei Kilometer das
sind 4 €, also ziemlich genau 2 € pro
Person in
New York hätte das wahrscheinlich 45 pro
Person gekostet ist einfach verrückt
es wirklich verrückt dann sehen wir mal
was die City so zu beaten hat hi
willkommen auf der Hanoi trainstreet die
vermutlich bekannteste Straße an Neuss
die jeder von euch schon mal auf insta
gesehen hat kostet uns keinen Cent und
eine Sache macht diesen mit Restaurants
und kleinen Shops über selten Ort
wirklich besonnen jeder von euch kennt
vermutlich die viralen Videos von tiktok
und Instagram in dem Leute ganz normale
in einer Bar sitzen und dann ein
richtiger vollwertiger Zug nur Metern
ihn vorbei fährt und genau auf dieser
100 m lang trainiert sind wir gerade der
Zug fährt bis zu 7 mal am Tag außer an
Wochentagen und natürlich waren dann
Wochentagen da an dem er nur einmal
fährt und das um 19 Uhr also kommen wir
später im Video noch mal darauf zurück
und dann haben wir unvorhergesehen
unsere Rettung kennengelernt wir sind
mit drei Jungs aus Deutschland ins
quatschen gekommen und es stellte sich
heraus dass Namen Vietnamese ist und
sich deutlich besser in der Stadt
auskennt als wir alle zusammen das ist
so ziemlich der Jackpot wenn man in
irgendeiner großen Metropole ist von der
man keine Ahnung hat man bekommt einfach
sofort das Gefühl mehr aus dem rausholen
zu können was vor einem liegt und damit
nicht nur ich das Gefühl habe sondern
ihr auch so jemanden an der Seite der
mehr für euch rausholt gibt es tagsfix
den Partner des heutigen Videos vielen
von euch geht's vermutlich wie mir
Steuern sind das letzte Thema mit dem
man sich in seiner Freizeit
auseinandersetzen will und trotzdem ist
es wichtig und immer dann wenn man sich
der Sache wirklich mal widmen will steht
mal vor demselben Problem eigentlich hat
man keine Ahnung man weiß nicht welche
Dokumente gebraucht werden und man weiß
auch nicht wie viel man jetzt überhaupt
von was einreichen kann und das obwohl 9
von 10 Arbeitnehmern durchschnittlich
mit einer Rückerstattung von sage und
schreibe 155 € rechnen können und das
komplett ohne Kopfschmerzen
vollautomatisiert mit Taxi fix geht mit
euch anhand von simplen Fragen alles
Wesentliche durch was euch hilft mehr
aus eurer Steuererklärung zu holen dabei
könnt ihr frei wählen ob ihr dafür den
Browser oder die App benutzt bedeutet
ihr könnt das lästige Thema Steuern von
überall entspannt angehen bedeutet auch
es gibt keine Ausreden mehr während ihr
den Fragen Katalog ausfüllt habt ihr bei
allen komplizierten Themen Erklärung und
Hinweise dabei damit ihr überhaupt wisst
was ihr da gerade ausfällt dabei
berechnet Tags fix jederzeit mit wie
viel Steuerung euch bei korrekten
Angaben zuständig das Beste daran
Berechnung eure Rückzahlung und der
Fragebogen kostet bis zum Abschicken der
Steuererklärung keinen Cent habt ihr am
Ende alle Fragen korrekt beantwortet und
die nötigen Dokumente eingescannt müsst
ihr nur noch eure Bankverbindung
angegeben und erst dann wenn ihr euch
entscheidet eure Steuererklärung
zusammen mit taxfix abzuschicken zahlt
ihr einmalig 39 € und 99 Cent alles was
ihr dann noch tun müsst ist entspannt
auf eure Rückzahlung warten holt euch
also mittagsfix von der Steuer zurück
was euch zusteht checkt den ersten Link
in der Videobeschreibung und spart als
Neukunde mit dem Code Dave 5 € auf eure
nächste Steuererklärung los ging es mit
einem Tempel müssen und das an einem der
so ziemlich wichtigsten Tage in der Weg
dahin dauerte etwas länger aber das mit
gutem Grund in der neu gibt es so
ziemlich an jeder Ecke einen Stand mit
frischem Obst oder exotischen Snacks man
probiert probiert probiert und alles
schmeckt nice und vor allem ist aber
alles unheimlich günstig selbst wenn man
ein wenig Touri prima bezahlt was man
gerne macht weil es immer noch günstig
ist irgendwann aber an allen Ständen
vorbei Richtung Tempel zur Opfergabe
gegangen 30.000 pro Person Eintritt das
ist Tradition und für gutes Glück hauen
wir jetzt gleich ein paar Scheine in die
Schreine für uns war der Tempel
natürlich eine super nice Erfahrung um
uns herum quasi nur Einheimische und man
hatte wirklich das Gefühl mal was von
der Kultur mitbekommen zu können anders
als beispielsweise in Tokyo das ein
richtig krasses U-Bahn-Netz hat das fast
von jedem genutzt wird passiert in Hanoi
der Transport meist auf der Straße
selber auf einem Roller über die App Rap
bestellte Fahrer hinten auf dem Roller
oder in unserem Fall mit einem
Rückschlag auf den ersten Blick ziemlich
chaotisch aber nicht chaotischer als in
jeder anderen Metropole in Südostasien
also jeder der schon mal im Bangkok war
kennt dieses Gefühl auf den Straßen zu
sein so ging es mit dem Richard einmal
quer durch die Stadt auf einen kleinen
Markt
und wie fast überall wird man überflutet
von Gerüchen und Eindrücken die man so
noch nicht kennt Fisch Fleisch Früchte
alles super frisch und ready man hatte
wirklich das Gefühl an Orten zu sein an
denen viele Einheimische unterwegs sind
was ist einfach alles ein bisschen
cooler wirken lässt weil man das Gefühl
hat die Stadt wirklich kennenlernen zu
können
aber geil
richtig geil hanoi ist eine unheimlich
große lebendige dynamische Stadt und das
kann schnell mal passieren dass die
Eindrücke ein bisschen überwältigen oder
vielleicht sogar stressen zum Glück gab
es zur rechten Zeit am rechten Ort ein
Massagesalon bei dem wir nach etwas
Verhandlung für 100.000 Dong 15 Minuten
massiert wurden und das sind weniger als
4 €, also für 15 Minuten rein in den
Massage Himmel und den Stress der Stadt
für 15 Minuten vergessen
[Musik]
konnten wir direkt danach auch
einheimisch zu Mittagessen und was soll
ich sagen für zwei Euro unglaubliches
Essen das sind Zwiebeln geröstete hier
unten sieht man noch die so Salami das
so vietnamesische Wurst Salami mäßig es
wird ein bisschen süß schmecken und das
ist so wie Leberkäse normalerweise ist
halt Fischsoße man Leute mögen Fischsoße
nicht weil es halt sehr streng sehr
stark nach Fisch liegt das Ding ist aber
sehr verdünnt bisschen Zitrone ein
bisschen Zucker rein das ist halt kann
man essen geil geil für solche
Erfahrungen für so gutes Essen so wenig
Geld zu bezahlen
hast richtig geil also ist ein absoluter
Traum das muss man schon sagen der fun
factor in dieser Stadt ist wirklich hoch
gefühlt an jeder Ecke gibt es irgendwas
zu entdecken und natürlich ist auch viel
auf Touries ausgelegt die Angebote
werden aber auch von ziemlich vielen
Einheimischen genutzt wie zum Beispiel
die Bier Street genau dort sind wir
eingekehrt und konnten für 2,30 € pro
Feature mit allen Jungs gemeinsam
ziemlich günstig Bier trinken also
richtig günstig sobald man den Pitcher
zugewiesen bekommen hat hat man den
einfach behalten es gab keine Bedienung
am Tisch sondern man musste reingehen er
wurde dort wieder aufgefüllt man hat die
ungerechnet 2,30 € bezahlt und konnte
den Pitcher wieder mit rausnehmen ich
habe einen davon bezahlt und die Runde
damit einmal glücklich gemacht wir waren
aber ja zu 6 und jeder hat diese Aufgabe
einmal übernommen ich bin also mit 2,30
€ gut dabei gewesen die ganze Aktion auf
der Bier Street hat aber dazu geführt
dass wir alle ziemlich Hunger bekommen
haben weswegen wir uns dazu entschieden
haben ein absolutes Festmahl direkt am
Straßenrand zu uns zu nehmen hier sitzen
alle und Essen zu haben und man sieht
viel von der Stadt alle anderen sind
auch auf dem Roller unterwegs und wir
sind überall Shops ja was soll ich Euch
erzählen äh ist alles bestens wir fahren
hier ganz entspannt viel Stadtverkehr
deutlich schneller als mit dem Auto
deutlich günstiger 1 Euro wir sind jetzt
seit 15 Minuten unterwegs ich denke wir
sind noch fünf Minuten unterwegs mega
mega gut es ist einfach so dass man mit
dem Roller am besten am einfachsten am
schnellsten am günstigsten in
Südostasien in den meisten Ländern vor
allem in den Städten unterwegs ist und
so ist es ja auch goodbye ich bin
komplett dann der ganze Tag komplett
vollgepackt mit Action Abendessen mit
allen zusammen riesen Hotpot wir haben
gegessen bis zum get no eine Stunde lang
gegessen mit mir mit Getränken wir haben
auch nichts geachtet also riesen Essen
Riesentafel komplett krank ich glaube
wir haben in diesem Format noch nie so
günstig gegessen das ist bis dato Status
Quo an günstig leben die Sonne
untergegangen und wir waren gut gestärkt
bedeutet wir haben uns auf dem Weg
gemacht zu Training um endlich den Zug
zuzusehen zielgerecht sind wir dort in
der Bar eingekehrt der Barke hat uns
sehr freundlich empfangen und ein paar
Drinks aufgegeben bis dann um 19 Uhr
pünktlich die Nordsee fahren kann die
wichtigste Bahn in ganz Vietnam 36
Stunden bis in den Süden des Landes
ausgegeben haben wir so viel dass ich
euch nicht mal damit langweilen will
dass alles aufzuzählen deswegen ist das
hier die Liste und wir merkt wir haben
uns wirklich nicht zurückgenommen ich
habe das jetzt einfach mal grob
überschlagen laut meinem Rechner 1
Millionen 642000 das ist 63 € und 15
Cent sind inklusive Hotel inklusive des
ganzen Transports inklusive des Biers
inklusive des Essens der Massage des
Richters der Sachen an den Ständen und
das ist wirklich geisteskrank weil ich
natürlich in diesem Videos versuche das
maximale für euch rauszuholen nichts
auszulassen und eigentlich immer die 100
€ komplett ausschöpfen will ich es
dieses Mal aber nicht mal hinbekommen
wir hatten einfach nicht mehr Zeit ich
weiß nicht was ich an diesem Tag noch
heute machen sollen und die restlichen
eine Million Dong auszugeben und wie
immer kommen wir damit zum wie sehr
lohnt sich eine Reise Ranking nach Hanoi
der günstigsten Stadt in Südasien
Anreise direkt von Frankfurt in den
nächsten Monaten für 600 € hin und
Rückflug innerhalb von 12 Stunden 30 mit
Vietnam Airlines wirklich vollkommen
okay man hat eine lange Reise dafür muss
man bezahlen ist natürlich aber nicht so
geil zu erreichen wie Malle oder
irgendwelche anderen Sachen in Europa
deswegen drei von fünf Location hat mir
richtig gut gefallen ich mag den Flair
der Stadt es hat mich richtig abgeholt
Südostasien eh komplett mein Ding ich
gebe vier von fünf Sternen fun Faktor
vier von fünf Sternen ganz klar ich
hatte eine wunderbare Zeit alles auf der
Straße super schnell super einfach
accessible hat richtig Bock gemacht und
dazu ist es natürlich einfach günstig
Wohlfühlfaktor und ich weiß nicht warum
in Panama habe ich mich ja nicht so mega
wohl gefühlt in Südostasien im
Allgemeinen und besonders in Neu ging es
mir aber richtig gut ich habe mich 100%
wohl gefühlt ich kann nichts anderes
geben als 55 ich habe mich dort sogar
deutlich wohler gefühlt als in großen
festlichen mega Metropolen wie zum
Beispiel New York noch mal hin Faktor 4
oder eher dreieinhalb von fünf Sternen
ich will auf jeden Fall noch mal hin
aber nachdem ich eine Menge andere
Reiseziel abgecheckt hat und es ist
nicht so wie Thailand dass mich beim
ersten Mal als ich da war so in den Bann
gezogen hat dass ich sofort noch mal hin
wollte wenn es euch gefallen hat lasst
mir gerne ein Like da vergesst nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren um keine der
kommenden 100 € in Videos zu verpassen
ich wünsche euch eine schöne Zeit hier
auf Youtube tschüss